when i first saw mario kart live i
thought it looked sweet and i couldn't
wait to have it
and then i remembered i have two cats
and they are
not going to have this [ __ ] there's
megatron who is as
beautiful as she is spunky and then
there's lily who's a princess with a
tarnished heart of gold and they're not
the only obstacles i
have i also live in a studio apartment
so with all that in mind
there's a few challenges in rl that i
have to deal with in order to play
the ar mario kart game but that isn't
enough to stop me from spending company
dollars
to make my dreams come true even if it
means pissing off my cats so first
building a course was actually pretty
easy because
thankfully my sofa is just directly in
the middle
of the room making it a already a basic
kind of oval circuit shaped thing and
during that time the cats
really didn't seem to mind but that
could also be because they
didn't know what was coming yet
[Music]
at the beginning the cats were curious
as to be expected but
also in their nature they eventually
very quickly stop
giving with every race they just got
more
and more uninterested with megatron
becoming a spectator
cheering silently to herself in the
corner while really
uh yeah
i think they loved it
[Music]
megatron what did you think of mario
kart live
[Music]
wow
lily what did you think of mario kart
[Music]
live
so when you're playing it it actually
genuinely feels exciting and impressive
like
really like a mario kart game but the
moment you see it in reality
the way my cats do uh it looks
a whole lot less thrilling and i think
megatron and lily's
reaction can attest that as for the
second obstacle which was
my living space it was actually quite
seamless and super easy to set up
that is until i started building other
courses that went into different rooms
like my kitchen where
the car just completely lost signal with
the system now i'm sure if i had it
handheld
and was in there it'd be fine but trying
to sit on my sofa and
capture footage and sprawl out between
this space it
very quickly did not seem doable but hey
maybe it was just me that was just my
own experience with the game
and please let me know that i did not
harm my cats while making this video i
maybe spooked them but i didn't harm
them
i love them too much
[Music]
you